en fait n'avait pas l'air comme ça mais
je raisonne voilà pardon pardon à julien
à redon à simon je vous aime
voilà c'est tout vous êtes souvent on
rigole sur ma vie sans les mariages etc
c'est vrai que j'ai plein de vie on va
on va rappeler votre vie bajra parce que
mine de rien il ya plein de gens et
plein de jeunes gens qui savent pas
vraiment qui vous êtes
benjamin castadi oui ce n'est pas
seulement ce présentateur du nord vous
avez une famille extrêmement célèbre
faut savoir votre grand père c'était ils
vont autant c'est un des plus grands
acteurs
voilà et chanteurs ont vraiment qu'on
ait connu en france sert des mecs les
plus célèbres mais voilà il est du music
hall et même de tous voilà c'est vrai et
votre grand mère simone signoret immense
actrice votre père jean-pierre comédien
jean-pierre castaldi votre maman y voit
la comédienne voilà et c'est vrai que
vous déjà je sais que vous écrivez un
livre sur notre famille ouais vous allez
révéler des secrets de famille n'ont pas
de secrets a pas de secret jeu fédérer
vd moi même mes canons non c'est vrai
que moi j'ai jamais su monsieur marie
beaucoup de fois et c'est vrai que moi
vous êtes mariée deux fois pour les
belges se marier quatre fois cette fois
hélas assez souvent et c'est vrai que
dans l'hérault dès que j'ai dans ma vie
c'est vrai que j'ai eu et j'ai eu trois
enfants trois garçons
alors on va on va on va rappeler trois
enfants d'abord et c'est 3 février
julien dont c'est l'anniversaire ce soir
d'ailleurs le grand la wii simon
benneteau alors c'est tous de la même
façon c'est pas la même portée non alors
alors dites-nous bas alors julien pierre
julien et simmons et c'est avec valérie
et nous votre première femme oui c'est
avec flavie donc à fait d'accord et
c'est vrai que bon et enzo me suis
plutôt beaucoup occupé même si on a
divorcé assez tôt et flavie julien jeu
quand je suis parti dames et trois ans
mais sinon il y avait neuf mois cette
eau et ça donc pardon
voilà donc vous voulez ce soir si c'est
con que sur les véhicules
non mais c'est vrai parce que je rate
beaucoup de choses maintenant avec lui
parce qu'il est à la maison parce que au
sport ensemble on se parle et c'est
super je suis très heureux en fait
n'avait pas l'air comme ça juste résonne
voilà pardon pardon à julien pardon à
simon je vous aime voilà c'est tout
benjamins
pour les téléspectateurs soit vouliez
dire pardon à vos enfants parce que vous
trouvez que vous n'y étiez pas s'est
présentée j'ai prêté l'an passé notre
carrière c'est quoi c'est la carrière
c'est quand on est amoureux vous est ce
que c'est on est une femme on vit 100
ans on vit ses astuces histoire d'amour
il ya forcément des victimes et les
victimes malheureusement c'est souvent
les enfants parce qu'on est on pense à
soi parce qu'on est égoïste on va là on
vit une histoire d'amour on a envie de
la vivre pleinement
voilà et on n'est pas là moi je suis
parti trois ans en amérique donc j'étais
très peu vu lui la veille il avait neuf
mois et j'avais une sorte d'amour avec
la vie donc voilà oui c'est évident
qu'ils ont senti que j'étais pas présent
mais attends ça va mieux je suis content
vraiment je suis très heureux y vit avec
moi le si beau
aujourd'hui vous avez l'impression ce
que c'est si on se connaît bien
j'ai l'impression qu'aujourd'hui vous en
donner même encore plus voilà je suis
est maintenant mais j'ai la chance
d'être j'en ai deux homos sauce aux
montois takita jebba ggn zoé simon et
avec les défis d'ordre
enfin j'ai une grande famille qui
vraiment recomposée et c'est très
agréable parce qu'il était mon jeu je
fais des choses que j'ai jamais fait
dans ma vie parce que effectivement
quand on est animateur moi j'ai connu
succès assez jeune à 30 ans avec l'offre
où on se brûle les ailes et on passe à
côté d'eux un moment avec quand vous
étiez dans le love quand vous étiez dans
un succès incroyable
vous avez un moment j'ai dit je passe à
côté je vois mes enfants grandir une
robe se dit pas un mot
ce qui est fou c'est que c'est pas quand
on le vit c'est après parce qu'il fait
qu'ils vont y aller il ya des rancoeurs
les julien et sinon ils ont été en
colère on le sent un enfant et be parce
que c'est compliqué au début parce
qu'ils ont plein de reproches hipkiss à
pâques on l'exprimé parce qu'un enfant
il va vous dire des choses dans le
mauvais ordre toujours sur un mur sera
un détail à vous souhaiter à la gueule
des tas de choses qui font très mal
donc moi aujourd'hui je suis très
heureux parce que je raterais beaucoup
de choses avec avec mes trois enfants
avec simon parce que c'est lui que j'ai
le je pense que le moins vu et c'est
vrai que ce matin j'étais au sport avec
lui c'est génial oui là il a 19 ans on
fait plein de trucs ensemble
aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire de
julien julien hillat il ya quelques
jours il a 23 ans 3 23 23 dans l ain
julien il est là ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier julien
les gauchistes mais la qualité est
évidemment très clos t'aime toi tu sais
que je t'aime mon chéri qu'est-ce qu'est
ce t'as envie de dire à ton papa ce soir
qui est un mec que j'adore tu le sais
regardez comme il est sensible suis là
déjà il va pas ses yeux quand il pleure
pas là mais sans rigoler quand il pleure
alors là on y est il a avoué bien qu'est
ce que voulait lui dire il a fait ce
qu'il a pu et sa chérie tu vois c'est ça
reste ton père tu fais il a fait il l'a
fait des choix il a fait il l'a fait
pour lui il les a faits pour nous aussi
parce que gmail manqué de rien jusque
voilà il le temps que tu ne rattrape pas
mais tu tues via pas d'âge pour changer
et il l'a fait aujourd'hui royal dit là
il a souvent chez lui
moi j'ai commencé un petit peu ma vie tu
vas j'ai quitté le nid est l'équité le
n'y a pas longtemps j'ai pris mon
appartement la lia il ya un an qu'une
caution
[Rires]
j'ai eu envie de rien il a été il a
quand même été là tant qu'il a pu
voilà j'ai dit c'est que j'élève tu as
envie de profiter de ton papa
aujourd'hui
ouais j'aimerais beaucoup je peux tu
adressé à lui dire qu'il restera lui
dire aujourd'hui je suis fier de toi il
le sait je suis je suis fier d'avoir le
père que j'ai et voilà il n'y a pas
d'âge pour
pour changer les choses et franchement
mais c'est l'heure actuelle voilà c'est
un père au top sur un perron au top et
vous voulez vous dire pardon ce soir
benji ses premiers trucs qui nous a dit
quand on a dit c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la journée internationale du
pardon et il a dit je veux dire pardon
mes enfants est-ce que tu comprends
voilà qui qui qui veulent vous dire
pardon où tu te dis moi pour moi il a
été toujours présent il
voilà je les ai pas ressenti comme lui a
pu le ressentir ehpad était présent ce
pas monsieur
il n'a pas été il a pas été très présent
mais mais pardon c'est trop facile c'est
tu peux pas on peut pas dire pardon
cessé leur grève mais j'ai pas lui
pardonner de ça et c'est il a eu la vie
il a vécu sa vie j'ai manqué de rien
peut-être d'un père un peu plus présent
mais voilà lui en veux pas du tout je
lui en veux pas parce que parce que
parce que c'est je pense que quand on
est face à
au choix qu'il a dû à faire enfin quand
on a la vie qu'il a eu forcément à un
moment où voilà il tu dois faire des
choix et il les a faits ça ne fait pas
de moi quelqu'un de malheureux loin de
là
[Applaudissements]
un amour jutin ah bon je te fais un gros
bisou bon anniversaire
mercialys et versa c'est un gros cadeau
[Applaudissements]
le coffret cadeau time of which he
allait mal c'est que tu as envie et des
voyages en grèce en ce moment j'ai
débrayage en relation un voyage en grèce
bah ouais si un je t'aime je te fais
partie en est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]